- [Voiceover] Hello,
grammarians, and hello, Paige.
- [Voiceover] Hi, David.
- [Voiceover] Paige, I
have a question for you.
- [Voiceover] What's up?
- [Voiceover] You like cheese, don't you?
- [Voiceover] Why, yes, I do.
- [Voiceover] So, Paige,
what I've just asked you
is an example of what's
called a tag question.
So I'm making an assertion
and then I'm actually
looking for confirmation;
so I'm making a statement and then,
consumed by doubt, I have to turn, comma,
and ask you for confirmation.
So I say: "You like
cheese", comma, "don't you?"
And so what's cool about
tag questions is that
they kind of follow this
positive-negative flow.
So it begins with a
positive assertion, like:
"Here is a thing that is
true", and then the doubt,
so you then negate it to ask the question.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] You can
also do this backwards
and begin with a negative assertion
and ask a positive question, like:
"This won't hurt", comma, "will it?"
And we're using the comma to perform
its separating function
because that's what commas do,
and separate between
the assertion and the doubt question.
And that's what tag questions are.
Sorry to just launch into it.
So today we're gonna
talk about tag questions,
direct address,
and using commas in the
context of yes and no.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] So, Paige, how are you?
- [Voiceover] Why are you asking me this?
- [Voiceover] Because it's
an example of direct address.
So if I start off an utterance
by directly addressing you,
it follows a pause, I
would say: "Paige," comma,
"how are you?"
- [Voiceover] I see.
That makes sense.
- [Voiceover] But also I'm
interested in your well-being.
- [Voiceover] Oh, well thank you!
I'm good.
- [Voiceover] Good.
So if you're directly addressing a person,
it doesn't have to be just Paige,
it could also be me, it could also be Sal,
whoever, you would say the
name followed by a comma
then the question, or whatever
the sentence was going to be,
like: "Paige, I'm going to
the grocery store later.
"Do you want some cheese?"
- [Voiceover] Right.
I do definitely want some cheese.
- [Voiceover] So then in
that response actually
you could have the final thing
we're going to talk about
today, which is yes and no commas.
So when you're answering a question,
whether yes or no,
you kind of use yes or no as
sentence adverbs, kind of.
It's an introductory
element, so you would say:
"Yes," comma, "I would love some cheese",
or "No," comma, "I hate cheese"
if it were like an
alternate-universe version of you.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, no,
I definitely love cheese.
- [Voiceover] But that's how it works.
You would use, say, yes or no
and follow it with a comma.
So this is just another example
of how powerful commas are.
You can use them in all these
different separating abilities.
So you can separate
between the tag question,
the positive assertion and
the negative question, like:
"You like cheese," comma, "don't you?",
or "This won't hurt," comma, "will it?"
You can use it in direct address, like:
"Paige," comma, "how are you?",
and in yes-or-no responses, like
"No," comma, "I hate cheese",
or "Yes," comma, "I
would love some cheese."
- [Voiceover] Commas are so powerful.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, for real.
- [Voiceover] The viewer can
learn anything, can't they?
- [Voiceover] Yes, Paige,
I believe they can.
David out.
- [Voiceover] Paige out.